hello and welcome to this video let's do
something else in this bronze storm we
know that he's plagued the Scotch game
all the time so I'll play the night walk
and see what he does Oh Bishop b5 that's
not good news super sharp stuff and I
have no clue no clue okay this shouldn't
be all that bad I hope
hmm actually five is kind of unusual
here but maybe it's not bad just stop
just stop his um boom stop his 45 sorry
for my voice age three I mean don't you
have enough Doug squared weaknesses
already so if you ever castled long in
the night off this this could be one of
those moments
soon looks very strange okay does it
even react to what I'm doing I was
threatening d5 I thought maybe not but
that was the point of all this just
wonder if he maybe we can set the Queen
yeah
yeah my development is not on that
gradient that's true if I the same
check
not too happy with this but yeah I
underestimated to the development issue
here strategically speaking black is in
fantastic shape but i'm not i don't have
development and it is this is of course
very important so not quite clear where
blema bishop should should go I don't
really have a good square available a
five maybe a for Bishop c5 it looks like
it weakens it weakens quite a bit cannot
go a form because of rupee aid yeah
maybe I have to do this it's a little
bit looks a little bit loose go hear him
what a talent he goes away so let's put
it to c5
even be five is kind of interesting try
to push it away gaining space let's do
it making us a little bit loose but ok
now i can go rook da daz III is hanging
so you cannot grab on CL on g7 maybe you
can play Knight to g5 maybe 95 maybe 27
Wow why was so low on time I don't even
know what took me so long but what today
what went where he has spent all that
time funny
position is probably okay okay wow that
looks somewhat shaky do I have a tactic
this form for 23 or something like that
kind of concerned here Queen g7 i think
i have 23 that should work yeah that
should work
where is he going I just move that okay
so Bishop to e3 would be good time
morning this one it cannot take we
should be three made and I'm threatening
maybe g5 getting rid of that pawn maybe
I can grab on 136 night 86 something
like that
maybe I should have taken taken on
before
check the cream entering is not good
news so this is probably going to be a
draw but the time is not good on my end
draw a third way of a metro I should
probably take that but I have an idea
one idea have track this one if you take
that I am going to have some chances now
I can go over to e5 hmm it doesn't do it
actually yeah I cannot do much um are
drawn it's a repetition actually okay
Abel's us probably had some chances for
sure it very tough so we have this
opening one thing that I probably should
have checked us over here actually if I
had Queenie three major oh that's
interesting clock that's dope fresh ok
probably I cannot take with the night
because of my peers have noted
here okay now this is certainly okay a
question is really this is plan that I
had with long castles was interesting
it's a very end very unusual in the
night wolf so this is why I felt tempted
hidden felt tempted to do it but
probably wasn't really leading to an
advantage the thing is really that
development this is so bad you should be
seven given by the engineer this is a
move that i briefly considered but i
mean this is not a problem this is this
is somewhat okay i thought about this
but Queen takes wasn't clear to me okay
cross-check and now create no porn sec
yeah computer is probably correct
everything it usually is that it is a
playable option so I played it in a more
conservative way internet cut somewhere
it's not yeah maybe b5 wasn't things I
can't do that oh sorry I can't do this
this is strong I am because he still
cannot take because of Queen d3m then
it's stronger to play without bt5 I was
mostly pushing it away so that i have d
8 but ahead anyway and here probably i
should get something but I didn't take
screen b6 it's also not a win or
anything yeah here yeah I should take
before I am miss this opportunity
and I thought about it but too late and
then g5 yeah that is probably going to
do it he had taken him I should have
prevented the opposite colors bishops
this is really a draw maybe I shouldn't
have put it h 52 now that I think of it
but the draw probability is very high ok
guys thanks for watching